bonjour christian jacob bonjour alors
depuis vendredi soir les réactions
n'arrêtent pas le gouvernement le
pouvoir exécutif se déploie on va dire
est ce que il a pris la mesure de la
gravité de la situation
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas parce que
la semaine dernière nous étions en
réunion avec monsieur darmanin qui nous
expliquait que peu de chose était
possible en fait dans cette loi sur le
séparatisme
je rappelle d'abord qu'au départ c'était
une loi contre l'islamisme radical après
c'est devenu une loi sur le séparatisme
maintenant on nous parle d'une loi sur
la laïcité
la réalité c'est qu'il faut poser le
débat sur l'immigration et sur le manque
de contrôles d'immigration et également
sur les mesures de rétorsion d'expulsion
de sanctions or tout cela n'est pas
évoquée dans le cadre du texte de loi
qui nous a présentés certes mais alors
ce matin peut-être que ça va changer je
ne sais pas ce matin monsieur darmanin
s'est exprimé il a dit va dissoudre des
associations qui ne respectent pas les
valeurs républicaines
il va expulser semble-t-il quelques
éléments radicaux en tous les cas
islamisée et de façon radicale et il
veut aussi revenir avec peut-être une
loi sur les réseaux sociaux pour essayer
d'éviter que cette haine se déverse
comme ça est ce que vous pensez qu'on
peut faire tout ça oui on la seconde a
quand même des barrières juridiques
aussi nous on a la droit on est un état
de droit donc mais curité liberté ça
fait parfois pas très bon ménage
mais la loi on peut la faire évoluer
depuis 2015 avec notamment avec eric
ciotti mossi avec olivier marleix que
c'est bien d'autres nous avons fait des
propositions en permanence encore la
semaine dernière le sujet des mineurs
non accompagnés
on a vu les risques qui est qu'il y
avait plus que c'était ont été concernés
par le précédent attentat sur ce sujet
de quelqu'un qui a bénéficié de cette
mesure
gadret qui n'était pas mineur du tout ce
n'est pas mineur du tout on accueille
plus de 40 mille mineurs
dix mineurs isolés dont bien souvent ne
le sont pas qui refuse de faire des
contrôles osseux pour vérifier leur âge
puisque ils peuvent leur ne peut faire
ces contrôles qu'avec leur accord
bien évidemment que s'ils sont pas
mineurs il accepte pas l'explosion
complète des titres de séjour de 275
mille titres de séjour si on veut
comparer avec le quinquennat nicolas
sarkozy c'est 50% de plus l'explosion
des demandes d'asile la france et le
devenue le premier pays où il ya le plus
grand nombre de demandes d'asile alors
que partout dans les autres pays
sa baisse la fermeture des lieux de
culte monsieur darmanin me disait qu'il
ne savait pas comment identifier un lieu
de culte 6,6 depuis 48 heures c'est
devenu possible on va voir mais en face
l'était pas la semaine dernière on est
aujourd'hui sur le fichier des personnes
qui sont inscrites pour prévention
contre la radicalisation il y à peu près
20 milles non sur ceux sur ce fichier
au moins 4000 sont des étrangers
qu'est-ce qu'ils font encore sur notre
territoire mais alors on accumule cela
parce que finalement les attentats on
vit avec depuis 2012 et mohamed merah
même si on a eu d'ailleurs bien avant
mais ça se répète et à chaque fois le
pouvoir exécutif
quels qu'ils soient d'ailleurs il dit
soit non ordre à quels qu'ils soient pas
quel qu'il soit parce que la droite
depuis 2015 et notamment je vous le
disais avec eric ciotti nous avons fait
des propositions en permanence ces
propositions n'ont jamais été reprise
encore la semaine dernière rien n'était
possible
alors j'espère qu effectivement
maintenant ça va le devenir jusque là ça
ne l'était pas alors les répéteurs
aux dires du gouvernement les
républicains ont une proposition à faire
elle a été portée ce week-end par
olivier marc l'ex notamment c'est celui
d'organiser un référendum d'initiative
partagée donc vous appelez à ce
référendum bleus alors c'est quoi un
référendum d'initiative partagée il faut
qu'ils 185 parlementaires qui ont fait
cela demande sénateurs ou députés et qui
est 4,7 millions de français qui signent
une pétition et les deux joints
permettent de regarder
un référendum est de passer par dessus
finalement la volonté du pouvoir
exécutif
l'exécutif peut inscrire cette loi s'il
inscrit il n'ya pas le référendum c'est
un moyen de pression je le dis
clairement que l utilisons parce que
c'est une procédure longue mais
lorsqu'on est dans l'opposition n'avons
pas d'autres possibilités
nous avons fait plusieurs propositions
de loi il est d'ailleurs prévu à
l'assemblée nationale qui est avant la
fin de l'année dans ce que l'on appelle
la niche parlementaire des républicains
une nouvelle proposition de loi sur ce
sujet ces propositions de lois ne sont
pas reprises parle par le gouvernement
donc aujourd'hui eh bien il faut
chercher à faire pression et d'obliger
le gouvernement à poser non seulement
l'ensemble des sujets mais y apporter
des réponses des réponses concrètes y
aurait-il n'a pas été dit at-il dans
cette proposition de loi que vous portez
il y à il ya plusieurs choses il ya tout
ce qui concerne à la fois les
possibilités d'expulsion des étrangers
qui santis situation irréguliè ce qui
bloquerait aujourd'hui ce qui bloque
c'est alors d'une part on un cadre
constitutionnel qui bloque effectivement
d'où la nécessité de modifier la cua jeu
modifier la constitution
philippe bas a fait une proposition de
bon sens qu'il faudrait que l'on puisse
reprendre je pense qu'on n'évitera pas
la modification de la constitution
on a aussi le sujet des réseaux sociaux
on est tous attachés à l'anonymat mais
moi ce que je demande que nous avons
demandé depuis d'ailleurs plus d'un an
c'est que les hébergeurs s'engage c'est
à dire que lorsque vous ouvrez un compte
sur des réseaux sociaux vous puissiez le
faire avec une pièce d'identité déposer
votre adresse de façon à ce que si une
enquête est ouverte et bien à ce moment
là on peut identifier l'individu puisque
vous parlez de ça sur les réseaux
sociaux est ce que c'est aux hébergeurs
de faire le ménage sur leur site ou
c'est au contraire à la justice
d'intervenir
le problème c'est qu'on attendait d'eux
on a nécessité vraisemblablement de
modifier nos textes
aujourd'hui et pour pouvoir le faire il
faut trouver le cadre juridique et le
cadre juridique on peut la voir avec les
hébergeurs d'accord caustique alors un
référendum ça serait quoi la question
quel serait le sujet c'est plusieurs
questions on va préparer le
va préparer ce texte en partant des
différentes propositions de loi qui ont
été déposées
je disais tout à l'heure notamment celle
celle d'eric ciotti
on aura dans ce cadre là à la fois les
mesures d'expulsion et d'obligations
d'expulser monsieur 85 % aujourd'hui des
décisions d'expulsion ne sont pas ne
sont pas appliquées
la fermeture des lieux des lieux de
culte ou là vraisemblablement il y aura
besoin de modifier de modifier la
constitution
on a aussi la conditionnalité de l'aide
lorsque l'on fait de l'aide aux pays en
voie de développement d'obliger en
condition que ces pays et le
l'obligation de reprendre le
ressortissant c'est ce qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui
il faut un peu serré oui mais on peut
faire évoluer la loi sur les conditions
d'un du droit d'asile on peut aussi
faire évoluer la loi
si on le veut il y attentionnel
législatives qui vont revoir alors tout
à fait pourquoi le nous l'avons pas fait
avant écoutez depuis depuis les
attentats de 2015 nous avons cessé de
faire des propositions alors parfois
quelques propositions ont été reprises
mais mais on voit bien qu'il y a eu un
laxisme sur le contrôle de l'immigration
explique aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a pas de
lien entre le laxisme sur le contrôle de
l'immigration le communautarisme et le
terrorisme c'est se voiler la face
oui la preuve c'est que la plupart enfin
les derniers attentats qui ont été
commis ont été commis par des jeunes qui
venaient de l'immigration et c'est le
cadre de ce jeune russe ce tchétchène
rené labissonnière pakistan le séjour
way qui venait d'obtenir son titre de
séjour
est-ce qu'il faut pas aussi
revoir la façon dont la justice
il ya un travail aujourd'hui est ce que
vous estimez que les magistrats
vis-à-vis de ces problèmes là sont trop
laxistes
je pense qu'il faut que le cadre la loi
de leur permettre ensuite ce qui est
certain c'est qu'il faut accélérer les
procédures
on voit bien que les procédures sont
souvent très longues qu'il y a parfois
un manque de moyens de la justice
d'ailleurs nous avons fait nous des
propositions pour renforcer les moyens
de la justice c'est c'est indiscutable
mais il faut aussi que le cadre légal le
permettent et est aujourd'hui il faut
faire évoluer notre droit tout ça peut
se faire d'ici à la présidentielle a je
pense que oui nous avons un support
législatif il faut le faire évoluer
quand monsieur darmanin nous dit qu'on
ne peut pas fermer les lieux de les
lieux de culte qui a des difficultés
pour pour expulser qu'on ne peut rien
faire sur les titres de séjour ni sur
les mineurs isolés tous ont peu modifié
par la loi
oui et ça ça ne peut se faire que s'il
ya une unanimité à l'intérieur de la
majorité présidentielle non est-ce que
s'il ya besoin d'une majorité oui et
vous voteriez de saint aubin les
propositions que nous avons faites
nous avons toujours voté à chaque fois
que des lois permettaient de favoriser
la lutte contre le terrorisme laquelle
collant le groupe des républicains
toujours voter les textes
si le projet de loi qui s'appelle
maintenant laïcité intervient avant la
fin de l'année normalement ça devrait
être le cas au mois de
au mois de décembre prochain est ce que
vous le vôtre et ce projet voir le
problème c'est que il faut là aussi
accéléré procédure au mois de décembre
prochain
c'est la présentation en conseil des
ministres ouais et donc un texte comme
celui là où la navette une navette
parlementaire fait qu' il sera
opérationnel à la fin de l'année dans
les meilleures conditions
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
faisons ce reproche au président de la
république est assez gouvernement alors
plus à son précédent gouvernement
l'actuel viens viens d'arriver mais aux
deux pendant trois ans ils n'ont rien
fait rien fait sur ce sujet je vous
rappelle que emmanuel macron annoncé un
grand discours sur la laïcité sur séché
en 2018 2018 il y a fallu deux ans pour
faire le discours
combien de temps pour préparer la loi on
attend est-ce qu'il faut revoir aussi la
sécurité des établissements scolaires je
pense qu'il faut renforcer le meurtre
l'a enfin l'assassinât n'a pas eu lieu
dans une range d'ordre mais c'est la
protection des enseignants oui faut
revoir
il semble que cet enseignement cet
enseignant n'est pas bénéficier de
toutes les protections alors moi je n'ai
pas l'ensemble des éléments du dossier
mais ce qu'on peut en lire dans la
presse il ya une plainte de déposée et
la protection un semble t'il de sa
hiérarchie semble t-il pas été assurées
au delà de celle de son chef
d'établissement et ça c'est un problème
qu'il faut revoir complètement sur une
protection totale de nos enseignants
dire l'école ce sont les enseignants
c'est pas les parents d'élèves
c'est pas les associations qui font la
loi dans l'école de problème ce sont les
journalistes qui sont visés ce sont les
enseignants se peut être les politiques
aussi
c'est un problème majeur ça la
protection bien évidemment mais mais
l'enseignement est un j'ai envie de dire
un sanctuaire parmi les sanctuaires
c'est à dire la liberté d'enseigner les
les programmes les programmes ce n'est
pas préparé encore une fois par telle ou
telle association
si l'enseignement français ne convient
pas on reste à l'étranger est ce que
vous allez demander un grand débat à
l'assemblée nationale sur ce problème du
terrorisme - les grands débats etc
il ya besoin de ces moments il faut
resserrer motion mais au-delà de ça
maintenant il faut faire il faut un
texte que le ministre d'intérieur le le
premier ministre présente un texte le
plus rapidement possible c'est ça que
nous attendons et alors votre référendum
d'initiative partagée quelle est la
prochaine mesure qu enfin là la
prochaine étape pour vous pourrez comme
chez soi voire impossible
on va voir ce qui va se passer là dans
l'est dans les jours qui viennent on est
capable de préparer un texte sous 15
jours
moi j'attends de voir si le gouvernement
a pris la mesure de la situation et si
oui ou non il y à un texte avec des
mesures précises que je viens d'évoquer
qui seront déposés et à ce moment là
vous verrez si vous continuez votre
démarche compartiment d'accord nous
sommes avec le président des
républicains ce matin député de
seine-et-marne christian jacob et on
continue avec vos questions sur
internautes avec jean baptiste say
nature
bonjour jean baptiste ont joué aux jo
question bonjour alors une première
réaction c'est sur twitter geneviève
elle souhaiterait que les républicains
portent des valeurs plus à droite
notamment sur la sécurité vous lui
répondez quoi je pense que ces valeurs
et sont largement porté j12 l'évoqué ce
que ce que nous regrettons aujourd'hui
c'est qu'un certain nombre de mesures et
disparus n'ai jamais été remis en place
ils ont disparu sous la gauche je pense
je pense aux peines plancher je pense
aussi en matière de contrôles
d'immigration une mesure que nous avions
voté qui évitait ces appels d'air de
dire pour bénéficier de prestations il
faut un minimum de durée de cotisation
sur le minimum vieillesse on avait
imposé c'est moi qui avait porté cet
amendement à dix années de cotisations
pour bénéficier du minimum vieillesse et
beaucoup d'autres mesures comme celles
ci la gauche les a supprimés et le
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron ne les a
jamais rétabli
autre question andré andré vous reproche
le surplus de communication de
l'opposition dans laquelle vous êtes
aujourd'hui mais vous le manque
d'efficacité au pouvoir est ce que vous
comprenez ce surplus de communication
l'impression d'un militant qui se dit en
fait on parle beaucoup mais quand ils
ont après quand on est dans l'opposition
c'est sûr que c'est plus compliqué
d'agir là où nous agissons et vous vous
êtes député la nouvelle wii dans
l'opposition à l'opposition là où nous
sommes au pouvoir on l'a vu dans les
mairies nous avons gagné à nous seuls
50% des mairies des collectivités
territoriales nous sommes au pouvoir et
nous agissons et ça se voit et quand on
compare les résultats en matière de
contrôles d'immigration ou de sécurité
sous le dernier quinquennat où nous
avons exercé le pouvoir quinquennat
nicolas sarkozy on peut faire les
comparaisons sans difficulté notamment
sur l'immigration alors on reste sur les
républicains alain alain ils vous
reprochent d'avoir des matches seront
compatibles aux républicains et c'est ce
que ça vous ennuie vous demande-t-il
il part notamment de christian estrosi
christian estrosi à sa liberté
d'expression
mais au-delà de cela ce qui les
dernières propositions qu'il a fait non
car ne pas la position qui est celle des
républicains nous préparons nous voulons
préparer les départementales sections
départementales et régionales dans la
plus grande clarté
comme nous l'avons fait au municipal là
où nous avons été ambiguë ça nous est
arrivé sur quelques villes
nous avons perdu donc faut savoir tirer
les enseignements les gens attendent de
nous qui est de la clarté et c'est ce
que nous ferons régional et au
département
alors on parle beaucoup de terrorisme
mais il ya aussi évidemment la crise
sanitaire et 7 christianites sanitaire
fait réfléchir pas mal de responsables
politiques qui disent peut-être qu'il
faut repousser les élections régionales
et départementales quelle est votre
attitude est votre position là dessus si
ça se fait ça ne peut se faire que sur
des pour des conditions sanitaires très
clair c'est à dire si nous sommes
confinés effectivement en revanche il
est toujours compliqué d'expliquer qu'on
peut prendre le métro on peut prendre le
bus que l'on peut travailler que l'on
peut faire ses courses mais que la
démocratie ne peut pas fonctionner ça
j'ai un peu de mal donc ça ne peut pas
être par opportunisme politique
je le dis en notamment au gouvernement
mais c'est quelque chose sur lequel vous
travaillez enfin vous est ce avec la
norme et non parce que les conditions
sanitaires qui seront celles du mois de
mars je ne les connais pas au jury
oui bien évidemment donc moi je
considère encore une fois qu'à partir du
moment on peut voyager travailler on
peut lire ses courses j'en passe je ne
peux pas aller voter
d'accord autre question yoann rappelle
que vous avez commencé en tant que
chiraquien quels ont été les positions
aujourd'hui de jacques chirac face à
terroristes face au terrorisme il pas
plus grande clarté je vous rappelle
d'ailleurs que une des lois que monsieur
macro ont jamais été capable de prendre
mille se prononcer sur ce sujet celle
l'interdiction du voile à l'école c'est
une des 6 milliards prise par jacques
chirac en 2004
et quand monsieur macron dit que le
voile dans l'espace public ce n'est pas
son problème
imaginez que jacques chirac ait réagi de
la même façon nous en saurions ou
aujourd'hui sans cette loi la même façon
que nicolas sarkozy l'a fait avec la loi
qui était initialement terres de jean
françois copé sur la burqa si nicolas
sarkozy avait réagi que monsieur macro
on en serait où nous avons là deux
exemples de présidents qui ont agi alors
2004 on sait que la loi sur le voile à
l'école elle a permis de résoudre ce
problème puisque semble-t-il kippa de ya
pas de jeunes femmes qui se présentent à
l'ong
elle est respectueuse celle sur la voie
publique la loi dite copé est plus
compliqué à faire à faire respecter sur
la voie publique non mais ça c'est de la
responsabilité directe du ministre de
l'intérieur
cette loi et doit être elle doit être
appliquée respecter effectivement c'est
pas simple quand même mon nom mais mais
le cadre légal et la cie les policiers
ont les instructions pour le pour le
faire et elle doit être appliquée c'est
de la responsabilité du ministre de
l'intérieur
est ce que le problème se pose par
exemple dans son application dans votre
département seine et marne est ce que
vous avez déjà eu des remontées qui
montre ici je raisonne sur sur ma ville
non non en revanche oui il ya des
secteurs en seine-et-marne où le sujet
plus plus sensibles mais mais là où les
policiers réagissent et sera accompagné
par leur hiérarchie ya pas de
difficultés
dernière question oui justement vous
parlez du terrain effectivement de la
seine-et-marne marion vous reproche de
raboter pour la réintroduction des
mimiques ou non mais ho nicotine aux ide
tarder c'est un sujet très important
qu'est ce que comment est ce que vous
réagissez ça se reproduit je l'assumé
complètement
parce que ça permet d'une part les
néonicotinoïdes sont des insecticides
qui sont sur des graines enrobées c'est
un peu technique a notamment été reçue
en turquie la protection un impact sur
la production de betteraves très peu
très peu parce que là où c'est un impact
c'est quand on peut pas utiliser ces
produits sur des graines enrobées vous
utiliser des pesticides donc avec des
pulvérisateurs et avec des pesticides
qui se retrouvent dans l'eau dans l'air
et sur le sol et sur le feuillage des
plantes là on est avec des produits qui
sont utilisés pour la betterave n'y a
pas de fleurs de betteraves les bouses
abeilles ne butinent pas sur les sur les
betteraves donc c'est au contraire le
minimum de risques ce qui permet de
sauver la filière et qui a objectivement
utilisé sur les betteraves très peu de
conséquences sur les abeilles
il n'avait pas d'abeilles qui vont sur
les champs de betteraves tout simplement
il faut se limiter à cette exception sur
la vitre av je pense qu'il faut
l'encadrer et puis très lucrative
travailler à des alternatives
est ce que c'est le cas aujourd'hui a
oui c'est le cas mais mais mais la
recherche n'obéit pas aux claquements de
doigts
si on n'utilise pas cela vous allez
avoir des pesticides répandus et pendu
avec des pulvérisateurs avec beaucoup
plus de riches où vous allez avoir tout
simplement une filière qui sait va
s'effondrer complètement
c'est je le rappelle 46 mille emplois
les mêmes qui sont opposés à cette loi
vont demain défilé parce qu'il y aura
des chômeurs et effectivement la filière
betterave 46 mille emplois est ce qu'on
est prêt à faire une croix sur le dos de
ses 46 mille emplois la question se pose
comme cela merci christian jacob merci
toutes vos réponses gestion jacques
homme qui était notre invité ce matin ou
au talk député de seine-et-marne le
président du parti les républicains
merci de vos questions chers internautes
qui était posée ce matin par jean
baptiste say berdja et à demain si vous
le voulez bien
[Musique]